(peaceful music)
- [Woman] Ever since I
can remember I've always
looked up to you.
When we were little girls,
I thought you were so cool.
I did everything I could to
dress and act exactly like you
because I wanted to be like you.
Now that I have my own taste in clothes,
obviously better taste, I want you to know
I still consider you an
incredible role model.
You've shown me what being a sister means.
Being a sister means
bringing chicken noodle soup
when she feels sick.
It means fighting over
who gets to ride shotgun
and sometimes letting her win.
Being a sister means
listening when she needs
to vent about something
stupid her friend did.
Teaching her how to talk to boys
and teaching her how
to talk shit about boys
when they break your heart.
Helping her with schoolwork
you mastered years ago
and by mastered I mean got a C- on.
Teaching her how to drive
both when the cops are looking
and when the cops aren't looking.
Being a sister means
picking her up from a party
when she's had too much to drink.
Being a sister means a
lot of different things
but most importantly it means
you always have a best friend.
Thank you for helping me grow from a girl
into a woman.
I love you.
(peaceful music)